>> Thank you so much for coming today.
I'm pleased to have with us Hugh Raffles this
afternoon.
Hugh is a professor and Chair of Anthropology
at The New School.
And he's also the author of In Amazonia: A
Natural History for which
he received the Victor Turner Prize in Ethnographic
Writing.
And his work in general addresses human concepts
of nature and the
relationship between humans, animals, and
other non-humans.
And his most recent book is Insectopedia,
which a collection of 26
chapters one for each letter of the alphabet
in which he considers
insects and our cultural relation to them.
Moving from cricket fighting in China to dances
with bees from insects
at 15,000 feet to fighting fruit flies.
He's written a very engaging exploration of
our relationship to the
physical world.
So please join me in welcoming Hugh Raffles.
[APPLAUSE]
Hugh Raffles: Thanks.
Thanks very much, Simon.
It's great to be here.
I'm very happy to be inside Google.
It's really an interesting experience and
thank you very much for
bringing me here.
What I'm going to do is talk a little bit
about the book, tell you a
little bit about it.
Then I'm going to read some -- a few sections
and then hopefully we'll
have time for some conversation afterwards.
So, um, as Simon said, this is a book about
-- a book about insects and
about human relationships to insects.
And it's very wide-ranging.
It covers -- it's historical.
It goes back to the 15th century and before.
There's actually some -- it actually takes
us back to Aristotle in the
Western tradition.
But it also is based around -- it also has
quite a bit about field work
which I've done in different places.
I'm an anthropologist and I like to travel
and meet people in a whole
range the places.
Then that's represented in the book.
[pause]
And as I said I'm an anthropologist but I'm
not an entomologist.
And when I started working on the book, I
actually didn't know very
much about insects at all.
I didn't pay them a lot of attention except
when they forced their way
into my life as they're inclined to do in
New York apartments, which is
what I live in.
And I certainly didn't understand them.
They seemed completely mysterious, apart from
mosquitoes I didn't
really have much of an idea of even what they
wanted.
But insects are fascinating.
And they took me over.
The more time I spent studying them, the more
-- the more interested I
got in them.
They're powerful; they're dangerous; they're
beautiful; mysterious;
they're difficult and much more.
And I discovered they're often at the center
of very fascinating
worlds.
Worlds that wouldn't exist without them.
An insect collector that I met in Tokyo, a
man called Daisaburo Okumoto,
told me that insect lovers are anarchists.
And I think that he meant that he loved these
impossible, unmanageable
creature because they're impossible and unmanageable
not despite the
fact that they are.
And I learned a lot from spending time with
people like him who'd
thought deeply about insects and about their
place in our lives.
Insects live in a completely different world
from us.
And it's one that we pay very little attention
to, but if we do start
to look, to listen, and to shift our sense
of scale, as many of the
people that I write about do, we enter a universe
that can dramatically
enrich the one that most of us normally occupy.
And that's -- that's the theme that this book
starts with.
It describes how scientists in the 1920s tried
to find out something
about the lives of insects who were invading
cotton crops in the U.S.
South.
They sent up planes to see if they could -- to
see what they could find
out about insect migration.
And as I'll try to describe in this passage,
they found a lot more than
they bargained for.
[READING]
"There are only a few flies and wasps in that
first trap at Tallulah,
but over the next five years, the researchers
flew more than 1300
sorties from the Louisiana airstrip and they
captured tens of thousands
more insects in altitudes ranging from 20
to 15,000 feet.
They generated a long series of charts and
tables, cataloging
individual insects as 700-named species, according
to the height at
which they were collected, the time of day,
the wind speed and
direction, the temperature, barometric pressure,
humidity, dew point,
and many other physical variables.
They already knew something about long distance
dispersal.
They'd heard about butterflies and gnats,
water striders, leaf bugs,
booklice and katydids sighted hundreds of
miles out on the open ocean.
About the aphids that Captain William Perry
had encountered on ice
flows during his polar expedition of 1828,
and about those other aphids
that in 1925 made the 800-mile journey cross
the frigid, wind-swept
Bering Sea in just 24 hours.
Still, they were taken aback by the enormous
quantities of animals they
were discovering in the air above Louisiana
and unashamedly astonished
by the heights at which they found them.
All of a sudden, it seems, the heavens had
opened.
They estimated that at any given time of day
on any given day
throughout the year, the air column rising
from 50 to 14,000 feet above
one square mile of Louisiana countryside contained
an average of 25
million insects and perhaps as many as 36
million.
They found ladybugs at 6,000 feet during the
daytime; striped cucumber
beetles at 3,000 feet during the night.
They collected 3 scorpion flies at 5,000 feet;
31 fruit flies between
200 and 3,000; a fungus gnat at 7,000 feet,
another at 10,000.
They trapped an anthrax-transmitting horsefly
at 200 feet and another
at 1,000.
They caught wingless worker ants as high as
4,000 feet.
And 16 species of parasitic wasps at altitudes
of up to 5,000 feet.
At 15,000 feet, probably the highest elevation
at which any specimen
has ever been taken above the surface of the
earth, they wrote, they
trapped a ballooning spider.
A feat that reminded them that spiders are
thought to have navigated
the globe on the trade winds and led one of
them to write that the
younger-most spiders are more or less addicted
to this mode of
transportation.
An image of excited little animals packing
their luggage that opened a
small eruption on the consensus around the
passivity of all this
airborne movement.
And led to a subsequent observation that ballooning
spiders not only
climb up to an exposed site -- a tree, twig,
or flower, for instance,
stand on tiptoe, raise their abdomen, test
the atmosphere, throw out
silk filaments and launch themselves into
a balloon or free, like
spread eagle, but that they also use their
bodies and their silk to
control their decent and the location of their
landing.
36 million little animals flying unseen above
one square mile of
countryside.
The heavens opened.
The air column was a vault of insect-laden
air from which fell a
continuous rain.
So stop, if you're inside, go to a window,
throw it open and turn your
face to the sky.
All that empty space, the deep vastness of
the air, the heavens wide
above you, the sky is full of insects and
all of them are going
somewhere.
Every day above and around us, their collective
voyage of billions of
beings."
Well, that's -- that's sense of -- sort of
sense of mystery about there
being worlds around us that we're not -- that
we're not at all familiar
with is one of the themes that continues through
the book.
But quite a lot of the book, as I said, is
based field research that
I've done in various places.
And I spent a few of the most enjoyable weeks
that I had in writing in
book in Shanghai.
And one of my chapters -- one of the chapters
in here is about people
there who train and fight crickets and people
who have a deep knowledge
about crickets.
Cricket fighting in China has a history that
goes back nearly a
thousand years and I go on to some detail
about this in the book.
And the part that I want to read you describes
some of what I learned
from a very experienced cricket trainer that
I met there, a man called
Master Fung, who was the director of a cricket
museum in Qi Bao which
is a suburb of Shanghai.
[Reading]
"All these crickets were collected here in
Qi Bao, says Master Fung.
Standing behind a table laden with hundreds
of great clay pots, each
containing one fighting male, and in some
cases, its female sex
partner.
Qi Bao's crickets are famous throughout East
Asia, he tells us, a
product of the township's rich soil.
But since the fields here were built on in
the year 2000, crickets have
been harder to find.
Master Fung's two white-uniformed assistants
fill the insect's
miniature water bottles with pipettes and
we humans all drink
pleasantly a stringent tea made from his recipe
of seven medicinal
herbs.
Master Fung's considerable presence, the prim
of his white canvas hat
rakishly angled, his jade pendant and rings,
his intense gaze, his
animated storytelling, his throaty laugh.
Michael, my translator, and I are drawn to
him immediately and hang on
his words.
Master Fung is a cricket master, confides
his assistant Miss Jao.
He has 40-years' experience.
There is no one more [INAUDIBLE, knowledgeable
about] crickets.
Twenty years ago, everyone tells us, before
the construction of the New
Shanghai gobbled up the landscape, in a time
when city neighborhoods
were patchworks of fields and houses, people
lived more intimately with
animal life.
Many found companionship in cicadas or other
musical insects that they
kept in bamboo cages and slim pocket boxes.
And young people, not just the middle-aged,
played crickets, learning
how to recognize the three races and 72 personalities,
how to judge a
likely champion, how to train the fighters
to their fullest potential.
How to use the pencil-thin brushes made of
yard grass or mouse whisker
to stimulate the insects jaws and provoke
them to combat.
They learned the rudiments of the three rudiments
around which every
cricket manual is structured: Judging, training,
and fighting.
When Master Fung and other experts tried to
instruct me in the
distinctions that allow them to judge a cricket's
fighting potential,
they use a taxonomy that first appeared in
Jia Shi-Dao's Book of Crickets,
a 900-year old manual of training and raising
crickets that's been
modified and supplemented but not overthrown
across the centuries.
The book outlines the fiercely complex system
for classifying crickets.
It brings request body color.
Jia identifies and ranks four colors: Yellow,
red, black, and white.
By contrast, most cricket experts I talked
to in Shanghai describe only
three colors: Yellow, green, and purple.
Yellow crickets are reputed to be the most
aggressive of the three but
not necessarily the best fighters, because
green insects, though
quieter, are more strategic and according
to the annual illustrated
list of cricket champions include a greater
number of generals.
Color is the first criterion by which crickets
are divided and it
confers an initial identity, that is held
to correspond to differences
in behavior and character.
Below these gross distinctions, however, is
the further set of division
into individual personalities whose total
number is often put at 72.
Below that, classification is based on an
agglomeration of numerous
physical variables, complex clusters of characters,
length, shape, and
color of the insect's legs and abdomen and
wings are all systematically
passed, as is the shape of the head.
Current manuals might include seven or more
possibilities and
differences in number, shape, color, and width
of the fight lines that
run from front to back across the crown.
Experts -- experts also consider the energy
of the antennae, the shape
and color of the animal's eyebrows, which
should be opposite in color
to the antennae.
The shape, color, translucence, and strength
of the jaws, the shape and
size of the neck plate, the shape and resting
angle of the forewings.
The sharpness of the tail tips, the hair on
the abdomen, the width of
the thorax and face, the thickness of the
feet and the animal's overall
posture.
The insect's skin must be dry, that is, it
must reflect light from
inside itself not from the surface.
It must also be delicate, like a baby's.
The cricket's walk must be swift and easy.
It should not have a rolling gait.
In general, strength is more important than
size.
The quality of the jaw is decisive.
Master Fung tells us that the trainer's task
is build on preexisting
natural virtues, to develop the animal's fighting
spirit.
This indispensable quality is revealed only
at the moment the insect
enters the arena.
Though a cricket might look like a champion
in all respects, though the
judgment of its physical qualities may be
correct, it can still turn
out to lack spirit in competition.
This, he insists, is less a matter of individual
cricket's character
than a function of its care.
It's the task of the trainer to buildup the
cricket's strength with
foods appropriate to its growth and individual
needs, to respond to its
sicknesses, develop its physical skills, cultivate
its virtues,
overcome its natural aversion to light, and
habituate it to new, alien
surroundings.
Fundamentally, says Master Fung, a trainer
must create the conditions
in which the insect can be happy.
A cricket knows when it is loved and it knows
when it's well cared for.
And it responds in kind with loyalty, courage,
obedience, and the signs
of quiet contentment.
In practical terms, this as quid pro quo,
because a happy cricket is
amenable to training and as its health, skill,
and confidence increase
under the trainer's care, so too does its
fighting spirit.
And as he was explaining all this, describing
the sexual regiment he
provides, outlining the many symptoms of ill-health
that one must be
alert to, displaying the purified water, the
home-cooked foods, the
various parts, explaining that everything
relies on communication and
that the yard grass is the bridge between
him and the insect, that in
other words, they understand each other in
a language beyond language.
Master Fung removed the lid from one of his
pots and in an emphatic
response to my increasingly unimaginative
line of questioning, took his
yard grass straw and barked orders at the
cricket as if it as soldier
-- this way, that way.
This way, that way.
And the insect, to Michael's and my real astonishment,
responded
unhesitatingly turning left, right, left,
right.
A routine of exercises that Master Fung eventually
explained increases
the fighter's flexibility, makes him limber
and elastic, and shows that
man and insect understand each other through
the language of command as
well as beyond it."
So a significant part of the book is -- involves,
um, as I said,
involves fieldwork in various places.
But an equally large part of the book is involved
with trying to think
through the ways that we -- the ways that
humans think about insects
and the ways that insects enter our lives
and enter our psyches in both
positive and negative ways.
And one thing that struck me throughout working
on the book was how
intense are the feelings that we have about
and around them.
And as I said, many of these feelings are
positive: The beauty of
butterflies, the wonder of fireflies, the
sweet nostalgia that can
overwhelm us with the sound of crickets or
cicadas but many are
negative.
And after I'd written a chapter about how
amazing bees are,
particularly honeybees, I wrote this chapter,
which is a short chapter
I want to read to you which is called My Nightmares.
[Reading]
"For a long time, I thought only of bees.
They crowded out all the others and this book
became just for them.
A book of bees and all their bee-ness.
All the physical capacities, all the behavioral
subtleties, all the
organizational mysteries, all the comradeship,
all that golden beeswax
lighting up the ancient world, all that honey
sweetening Medieval
Europe, all those bees timeless templates
for the most diverse human
projects and ideologies.
Bees took over.
But then a plague of winged ants invaded my
living room.
And after they left, I began thinking of locusts
and then beetles, all
those beetles.
And then caddis flies, and crane flies, and
vinegar flies, and
botflies, and dragonflies, and mayflies, and
houseflies, and so many
other flies.
Then one thing led to another and I came across
field crickets and Mole
crickets and Jerusalem crickets.
And then my friend Jessie sent me a Weta from
New Zealand and then
the 17-year cicadas emerged in Ohio.
And I discovered the thrips and katydids,
remembered the aphids on
California roses, and the summer wasps drowning
in water-filled jam
jars.
And then termites and hornets and earwigs
and scorpions and ladybugs
and praying mantises all dry in packets in
garden supply stores.
And then there were the mosquitoes with long
legs and the mosquitoes
with short legs and far too many butterflies
and moths of all kinds.
And I remembered what we already know, that
insects are without number
and without end.
That in comparison we are no more than dust.
And that this is not the worst of it.
There's the nightmare of the fecundity and
the nightmare of the
multitude.
There's the nightmare of uncontrolled bodies,
and the nightmare of
inside our bodies and all over our bodies.
There's the nightmare of unguarded orifices
and the nightmare of
vulnerable places.
There's the nightmare of foreign bodies in
our bloodstream and the
nightmare of foreign bodies in our ears and
our eyes and under the
surface of our skin.
There's the nightmare swarming and the nightmare
of crawling.
There's the nightmare of burrowing and the
nightmare of being seen in
the dark.
There's the nightmare of turning the overhead
light on just as the
carpet scatters.
There's the nightmare of beings without reason
and the nightmare of
being unable to communicate.
There's the nightmare of their being out to
get us.
There's the nightmare of knowing, and the
nightmare of non-recognition.
The nightmare of not seeing the face.
There's the nightmare of not having a face.
There's the nightmare of too many limbs.
There's the nightmare of all this plus invisibility.
There's the nightmare of being submerged and
the nightmare of being
overrun.
There's the nightmare of being invaded and
the nightmare of being
alone.
There's the nightmare of numbers, big and
small.
There's the nightmare of metamorphosis and
the nightmare of
persistence.
There's the nightmare of wetness and the nightmare
of dryness.
There's the nightmare of poison and the nightmare
of paralysis.
There's the nightmare of putting the shoe
on and of taking the shoe
off.
There's the slithering nightmare and the one
that walks backwards.
There's the squirming nightmare and the squishing
nightmare.
There's the nightmare of the unwelcome surprise.
There's the nightmare of the gigantic and
the nightmare of becoming.
There's the nightmare of being trapped in
the body of another with no
way out and no way back.
There's the nightmare of abandonment.
And the nightmare of social death.
There's the nightmare of rejection.
There's the nightmare of the grotesque.
There's the nightmare of real quick flight
and the nightmare of
classroom wings, there's the nightmare of
untangled hair.
And the nightmare of the open mouth.
There's the nightmare of long, probing antennae
emerging from the
overflow hole in the bathroom sink or worse
the rim of the toilet.
There's the nightmare of huge blank eyes.
There's the nightmare of randomness in the
unguarded moment.
There's the nightmare of sitting down, the
nightmare of rolling over,
the nightmare of standing up.
There's the nightmare of the military that
funds nearly all basic
research in insect science.
The nightmare of probes into brains and razors
into eyes.
The nightmare that if any of this should reveal
the secrets of locusts
swarming, of bees navigating or of ants foraging,
the seekers will
beget other seekers, the nightmares other
nightmare, the pupae other
pupae, insects born of micro implants, part-machine,
part-insect
insects.
Remote-controlled, weaponized, surveillance
Moths on a mission; beetles undercover.
Not to mention robotic insects mass produced,
mass deployed, mass
suicide nightmare insects.
These are the nightmares that dream of coming
wars, of insect wars
without vulnerable central commands, forming
and dispersing congealing
and dissolving, de-centered, networked of
net war of network-centric
warfare, of no casualty wars, at least on
our team.
Dreams of Osama bin Laden somewhere in a cave.
These are the nightmares of invisible terrorists,
swarming without
number, invading intimate places and unguarded
moments.
The nightmares of our age.
Nightmares of emergence, of a hive of evil,
a brood of bad people, a
super organism beyond individuals swarming
on their own initiative,
homing info on scattered locations on various
targets and then
dispersing only to form new swarms.
The nightmare of language, the language of
bees, nightmare begets
nightmare, dreams beget dreams, terror begets
terror.
Where are the bees now?
Collapsing in their colonies, gliding through
their plastic mazes,
sniffing out explosives, sucking out that
sugar water, getting fat and
weak on corn syrup, locked in little boxes
at airports, sticking out
their tongues on cue.
Who knew the tiny critters are so smart, said
the journalist.
Fuzzy little sniffers.
Buzz, buzz, buzz, keeping us safe, helping
us sleep easy at night."
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm happy to take any kinds of comments
or any kind of -- any kind
of conversation at all.
[PAUSE]
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> So if I go to Shanghai, can I go to a cricket-fighting
arena?
Hugh Raffles: Could you say that again?
>> If I were to go to Shanghai, could I go
to cricket battle arena and
wager on some crickets?
Hugh Raffles: If you went to Shanghai, could
you go to a cricket fight
and bet on it?
If you knew the right people you could.
>> It is illegal like dog fighting?
Hugh Raffles: Yeah, you know, gambling is
illegal.
So it's hard to go to a fight in which there's
gambling.
But people might take you if you know people
who do that.
But there are -- there is other cricket fighting.
There's some -- there's cricket fighting which
involves gambling but
people are also trying to promote cricket
fighting without gambling
more as exhibition matches or to demonstrate
this sort of cultural
sophistication of it which, you know, as you
can I hope from what I
read, it's a very developed, very -- it's
very elaborate knowledge
which is, and deep knowledge, which is connected
with it.
And so there are a lot of people who are trying
to encourage,
particularly encourage young people, to be
interested in that.
And to develop -- to develop their skills
in judging cricket -- and
judging crickets and raising them and training
them in a -- sort of in
a format which is the separate from the gambling
culture which has been
associated with it actually right from the
beginning.
I'm not sure how successful they're going
to be at doing that but
they're quite serious about doing it.
And it means that it's quite easy either to
see exhibition matches of
that kind or else you can go to markets, open
air markets, where people
sell crickets.
And people go, you know obviously people are
there buying crickets and
you can see crickets in that context.
And people have -- people have put on cricket
fights there where
they're just trying to show the strength of
the crickets that they're
selling.
So, um, there's sort of like displaying those
crickets.
As you can imagine, that's kind of a risk
because if the cricket loses,
then, you know, its value is going to go down.
So there's a bit of a risk involved in that.
>> Are the crickets also used for agricultural
purposes or things
besides fighting?
Hugh Raffles: Not that I know of and not those
crickets.
I think these crickets specifically are crickets
that are -- that
people train for fighting.
But there might be, it might be just something
that I don't know about.
Yeah.
Thank you.
[PAUSE]
>> What do you think we could tell the chefs
at Google to encourage
them to serve more insects?
[LAUGHTER]
Hugh Raffles: So what could the chefs at Google
learn?
Um, well you know, what can I say?
I'm vegan.
So personally, I don't think -- we should
be telling them how to cook
vegetables.
From what I can tell, they do that pretty
well already.
Yeah, quite a lot of people eat insects either
as some -- either as a
special food and like a luxury food, those
are the people who I met.
People in Asia who collect grasshoppers and
they eat them and sell
them.
But -- but generally, generally I've come
through reading this book --
reading this book -- from writing this book
to really like insects and
include them in the list of thing -- I wasn't
really planning on eating
them anyway but now I really included them
in the list of foods that I
don't eat.
Thank you.
>> Question from VC.
From San Francisco.
Hi there, thanks for coming.
So just curious, when people talk about the
insect worlds, they often
talk about them as almost alien because things
can just be so different
at that level.
Can you talk about maybe the most surprising
or interesting or
unbelievable thing you've learned about any
particular insect in your
journey researching this book?
Hugh Raffles: Actually about the insect rather
than the relationship
of the insect with a person?
I think actually the part that I read you
that you have spiders and --
we can call them insects for now, but the
spiders that actually will --
and these are flightless spiders, obviously
-- that will or that have
circumnavigated the globe on the air currents
that to me was one of the
most amazing things.
And in general that there are -- that large
numbers of insects are
constantly traveling in the upper -- well,
I don't know if it's the
upper regions the earth's atmosphere, but
say between -- it's not.
But say between 5 and 15,000 feet, you have
these large numbers of
insects that are traveling in the air constantly.
And that they're doing it not -- not in any
sort of passive way, but --
on a certain extent, I guess some of them
would be doing it in a
passive way.
But there's a lot of them who are doing it
in really quite an active
way.
There are -- they're leaving a place because
they want to leave it,
they want to find a better habitat or they
want to find more resources.
And they get themselves taken up by the air,
going into the air
currents, and then they can bring themselves
down at a certain point or
they have ways of getting themselves down
to the ground at a certain
point, and that to me was pretty mind blowing.
The invisibility of that.
And yet, yet its existence as a widespread
phenomenon.
In general, the -- it's something that continues
to fascinate me from
doing this book is just the, maybe the obvious
-- the obvious thought
that insects live in an entirely different
world from us.
Their senses are completely different.
There's probably a lot more synesthesia going
on, combination of senses
than we have.
And they're obviously much more sophisticated
and much more sensitive
to touch, say.
And they see in very, very different ways
from us.
So it's not so -- after awhile of doing this,
I've come to think that
it's not just that they experience the world
in a different way but the
world that they move in is actually an entirely
different world from
the one that we live in.
So we tend to think of the world that we live
in as being the world
because we experience it in a certain way
and we assume that it has
this objective reality that is the world.
But to -- to animals who live in a completely
different set, completely
different time space, have a completely different
-- sense of time from
us, completely different sense of space, and
whose relationship with
the world is entirely different, they are
actually for all intents and
purposes, living in a completely different
world.
And our paths interact, you know, and we meet
each other in all kinds
of circumstances, obviously, but we're meeting
across, almost like
across dimensions.
We're living simultaneously in entirely different
environments.
The things that we touch and the forces which
we're subjected to are
really entirely different to these, to these
other beings.
And we are also obviously completely different
to them we -- to a house
fly, we move at the glacial pace which is
which why it is so difficult
for us ever to swat one.
They see us in completely different ways and
they sense the air in a
very different way.
So that is me which this sort of I guess ontological
differences have
been things which I've been thinking a lot
about in writing this book
and trying to get to grips with in some way.
[PAUSE]
>> So I have a question.
So when you look at ants and stuff, they look
like they're not
individuals -- they're not like part of one
body like blood cells, like
not every ant has a mind of its own but the
whole colony has a mind.
And do you think some kind of different dimension
like you mentioned
that ants actually the whole organism is a
single organism instead of
each individual as a --
Hugh Raffles: Yeah, what the -- so, thinking
about ants, say, as super
organisms that -- so rather than working as
individuals but
collectively, they produce some kind of intelligence
collectively
rather than individually, yeah.
And a lot of people do think -- do think this
is the case that some of
these animals really operate on quite simple
algorithms individually
but when you put them together, then there's
-- there's some sort of
synergy that produces some greater intelligence
-- intelligence that is
greater than any individual that there's something
-- and people
working in artificial intelligence have worked
along these principles
in making -- and people work making robots,
for instance.
I'm -- well, one -- let me give you one example
of this that I find
kind of interesting which is work that a sound
artist called David Dunn
has done with -- he's -- he's recorded, a
few years ago, he recorded
the sounds of insects in ponds.
And so a community of water insects inside
a pond.
And at first, when you listen to his recording
and I guess I should say
that first of all, I don't think anybody else
had ever done this before
which seems surprising.
But people have -- there's a very limited
set of insects that people
have actually done research on and very little
research has been done
on insect sound communication, even on insect
hearing.
Because he's a sound artist obviously this
is what he's been interested
in.
So he's recorded the sound of insects in ponds
and when you listen to
it, at first -- at first you hear really a
lot of -- a lot of sort of
unconnected, disparate kind of noises or sounds.
A lot of clicking and a lot of buzzing this
sort of thing, whirring,
things that sound like static.
And after time as it builds up and it's probably
the way he's put the
recording together , but as it builds up , you
start to hear this very,
very complex -- very complex sort of polyrhythmic,
polyrhythmic sounds
emerging.
And that you get a sense -- this sense of
a very dense activity going
on.
Now, as a musician, he interprets that as
this very high level of
communication that's happening.
He -- what he hears and it is -- he hears
the rhythms in it, he hears
this complex rhythmic activity going on, and
he hears some insects
responding to other insects.
And he thinks of the pond itself as producing
some kind of -- or other
community within the pond as producing some
sort of communicative
intelligence which is happening within that.
You know, this, of course, is very speculative.
I'm -- you know, having done this research,
I'm very sympathetic to
these ideas.
The part of it that makes me pause a little
is the assumption that's
often in there that individually these insects
aren't particularly
interesting or these beings aren't particularly
interesting, it's only
when they get together that something significant
emerges out of the
collective.
So I like the idea that something significant
emerges out of the
collective, but I'm less convinced that individually
there's nothing
going on.
And that they only have -- they only have
any significance when you put
them together.
But there's -- there's certainly ways that
insects -- I guess we're
talking about social insects here in general.
Well, actually, I'll get back to that.
But in terms of social insects that collectively,
they're able to
produce phenomenal things.
If you think of termite mounds or ants' nests
or the kinds of decision
making processes that bees are able to go
through -- there is --
there's the ability to cooperate to produce
remarkable collective,
collective efforts.
And there's just collective achievements that
they're able to do.
And they're able to do it in general, say
within an individual hive or
an individual nest in a very cooperative way.
I mean generally they're able to reach consensus
after what appears to
be a process of debate and discussion.
But it seems also that there's a lot of communication
that goes on
between insects of different species either
communication that is to
warn other insects off and to, you know, sort
of defensive kinds of
communication.
Or there's also kinds of communication that
goes on to coordinate
behavior amongst species.
And the communications [INAUDIBLE] on through
vibration, through chemical
connections, all kinds of things.
And it's been a scenario which there's been
very little research, I
think.
But the parts fit -- that I've become quite
interested lately are the
ones that people, ones that have investigated
by people who haven't
had -- haven't had biological training so
much but have -- have brought
ideas.
I mean particularly like David Dunn, who brought
ideas from a different
domain, you know, as a musician.
And he started to see -- started to see forms
of communication that
have not been visible to insect scientists
who've been really caught up
in chemical communication and looking at chemical
cues from pheromones,
allomones and these kinds of things.
Cheromones.
That's really dominated the study of insect
communication for the last
30 or 40 years probably.
And so it's interesting to me that people
who come with very, very
different training, very, very different way
of thinking about it
they've started to be able to find new kinds,
new kinds of interactions
that have just been outside the paradigm of
investigation for the
last -- for the last period, anyway.
Yeah.
Thank you.
>> I know you spent quite a bit of time in
the tropics when you were
writing an earlier book Amazonia and I was
wondering if you have
impressions from the your memories there about
whether there's a
different place in the world that insects
have in the tropics than in
where we live in the temperate zone and whether
the relationships
between human and insects seem markedly different
thinking back on it
in that way.
Hugh Raffles: Yeah, that's a great question,
thank you.
He's asking whether or not in -- the first
research that I did was in
Amazonia, in a small community at the mouth
of the Amazon.
And he's asking whether or not there's a different
kind of relationship
that people with have insects there than you
would find -- you would
find here and, um, in the tropics in general.
Well, one thing -- one thing that I've been
thinking about recently in
that respect -- is that I'm not sure whether
this answers the question
in the way that you'd want -- but people,
you know, I've been struck by
as I've been going around and talking to people
about this book, that
one of the topics that comes again and again
is people's revulsion to
certain kind of insects, particularly to cockroaches.
And people talk a lot about their instantaneous
-- instantaneous
reactions to just sort of lash out and crush
a roach.
And I think this happens in -- I mean, I come
here from New York, but I
think it happens in California, too, but,
you know, there's this sort
of immediate response.
And part of that I -- I think is because of
the ways in which we
control, control our living space and our
determination to keep it as
free from -- as free from the kinds of beings
that we don't want in
there as possible and just sort to manage
it in this very strict ways.
And when I was -- when I spent time in the
Amazon, people had very
different relationship s, well, I'll say to
cockroaches, particularly
but to things coming into their living space
in general.
I mean unless they were animals which were
actually going to cause them
personal, personal pain or other kinds of
problems, they really weren't
too bothered by them.
And also when I was living there, I wasn't
bothered by them either.
And partly that has to with the architecture
of the spaces.
Space are much more open and they're much
more open to the elements as
well, at least the ones that I was in.
So -- and people aren't trying to control
what goes in and out in the
same kind of way.
So, you know, if there was snakes came in
the house, you know,
poisonous snakes, people were really bothered
by that.
When vampire bats came in the house at night,
people got very, very
worked up about that, which was I was kind
of grateful for.
And, you know, when there's mosquitoes at
certain times of the year,
when you have like clouds of mosquitoes and
you can't even sit still
because they're just biting you so badly,
then people took, you know,
as much action as they could against them.
And what we would do is set smoke off, going
in their houses to just
try to get rid of them, which actually was
almost as uncomfortable as
the mosquitoes themselves, right?
But roaches and things like that?
You know, they don't really do us any harm,
so nobody really was very
bothered by them.
They just scuttled around and everybody just
ignored them.
And so this is -- you know, I feel very strongly
this is a cultural
reaction that we have to them.
It's not something that's hardwired as many
people argue because of the
shape of them and the way they move and stuff
like that.
There's plenty of places that you can go to
where people don't respond
to them in this aggressive and negative way.
And it's fairly easy to train yourself not
to do that.
But, you know, spend a bit of time looking
at them, seeing how
interesting they are and trying to, I suppose,
if you got an interest
in it, trying to retain yourself not to respond
so immediately.
>> So just one last question, which in reading
the book, a theme of
taxonomies keeps coming up and seeing the
world -- see the macro
through the micro and vice versa.
And I was wondering if you could just speak
a little bit more about
that and that way of seeing insects and seeing
our sort of the world
around us.
Hugh Raffles: Yeah, he's asking about taxonomy
in general and
relationship between large things and small
things and seeing -- seeing
large things out of looking closely at small
things.
And -- I would say in terms of taxonomy one
thing that I think I've
learned from the book is that we use the taxonomies
that we use the
taxonomies that work for us.
So taxonomies seem to be -- I like to think
we use the taxonomies that
work for us.
Taxonomies are very -- are very instrumental.
So scientific taxonomy is a very useful thing
if you're trying to
understand evolutionary relationships.
And so it's a very useful thing if you want
to understand -- if you
want to say develop conservation programs
and this kind of thing.
But if that's not really your interest, if
you're interested instead,
say, in training crickets to fight, then it's
not really much use to
you to know that there are two species -- there
are two species of
crickets.
And that's really what you need to know and
then you want to protect
those crickets because this is their behavior
and whatever.
It's much more useful to know that there are
108 different -- I don't
know.
108 different races and 72 personalities.
And they have these different qualities, which
has no relationship --
you know, this is a classification system
which is actually more much
complicated than a Linnaean -- Linnaean classification
system and has
no relation to it but is much more useful
if you're trying to train
crickets to fight or trying to judge crickets
to fight.
So -- and of course in other -- in many places,
people have
classification systems which rely on size.
So they might classify things in a system
which would include insects.
It might also include seashells or grains
of sand or other small things
or say distant airplanes or something like
that.
That might be -- could be a system of tiny
things that move or tiny
things that don't move or whatever.
And it partly depends on what you're trying
to get out of system, what
it's useful for.
That tends to be how we organize the world.
But -- but the other part of your question
about finding large things
and small things, yeah.
I think this is -- this is a very helpful
way to look -- to look at
this book and to think about what I've been
trying to do.
And again, I go back to tell you about somebody,
somebody who I talked
to who had interesting ways of thinking about
this, which was a -- who
was a -- somebody you might know, a neuroscientist,
a Japanese
neuroscientist named Yoro Takeshi.
He's well-known in Japan for -- not just for
his neuroscience, but
because he's written these popular books of
social criticism about
Japanese society.
And he's also an insect collector.
And he collects weevils and other kinds of
beetles.
And he has -- he talked about people, he talks
about people having
mushy eyes, and mushy is a Japanese word for
insects.
There's actually another type of classification
but it would include
insects.
But it would spiders and all kinds of things.
And -- he's friends with Hayao Miyazaki, you
know, the anime, the
filmmaker.
And both of them were, um, obsessed with insects
as children and in
Miyazaki's movies, you can see very clearly
his interest in insects.
And it continues, if you think of something
like Nausicaa, and other
movies, there's very often these very positive
representations of
insects in them or insect-like beings, you
know?
And they both have argued that -- that these,
that insect eyes are
something that you can develop from this close
attention to -- close
attention to insects and spending time with
them.
And the kind of attention that you get from
really looking at something
very, very small and recognizing that for
that small thing, there's a
tremendous amount of variation in the world.
So that even the category like insects itself
just does -- well, this
might not be the way to put it, but something
like, you know, I want to
say something like does violence to the individual
insects involved but
that might not be quite, quite -- I mean they
would say that it
probably does more violence to us than to
insects because we don't see
the variety.
And a category like insects or like nature
those are so general that we
lose that sense of the individuality of the
beings.
And one of the things that Yoro said to me
was that for each insect --
it's not just that every tree is different
but every leaf is different.
And that if you can develop that kind of attention
to the -- to the
difference in the individuality of things,
then in his mind that can
also extend to more of an appreciation for
the individuality and
differences amongst people and more sort of
tolerance and respect for
people that can you also have from your relationship
with insects but
you can also see how the effects of more large
scale things say
something like climate change has effect on
tiny, tiny things too.
If you're studying something as small as insects,
then you can see the
effects of these large things on something
like an individual leaf
rather than say just a forest and that will
give you more of a sense of --
of the intensity of the effects and the breadth
of the effects as well.
So that's one of the ways in which you start
to see the relationship
between large and small.
For other people, of course, you know tiny,
tiny things are the best
place to see a microcosm of the whole universe
because it's in there
you see the tremendous detail.
And I suppose like the wonders of mysteries
of all things in many ways
right?
Because as you get smaller and smaller it
becomes actually harder and
harder in many ways to explain things.
You might say, well, it's all DNA or so whatever.
You might find the tiniest molecular unit
can you find that will be the
formative unit but fundamentally that really
doesn't explain very much
about the mechanics.
And there's some -- an awful lot of other
things which are left out of
that.
Thank you.
>> Please join me in thanking Hugh Raffles.
[APPLAUSE]